ciao sono gervasoni un buongiorno
buonasera la buonanotte in base a quando
vedrai questo video show
il comico dovrebbe dire in una realtà ci
tengo a dire giullare perché con i
giullari del quattrocento e
contemporaneo ballo per corti oggi sono
aziende enti manifestazioni non è
esattamente quello che mi piace fare
cioè rendere disponibile il mio talento
al servizio di altri sono molto felice
di essere qui per condividere con voi
una parte nel mio percorso con l'intento
di dare un valore alla comicità da un
punto di vista relazionale che non sia
soltanto un gioco fine a se stesso anche
se anche una leva per creare una
relazione migliore e perché no una
società migliore
io sono di milano città che che hanno in
più perché quello che sia nelle città è
la città che secondo me più di ogni
altra città in italia rappresenta di
criticità della società contemporanea la
velocità la tecnologia l'inclusione e in
modo particolare il mio personaggio
rapporto con gli occhiali se fossi
superman
racconta di un
milanese che vive in centro che ha la
doppia f figurata come obiettivo e
soprattutto al suo antagonista anche il
giardino colui che vive fuori dalla
dall'agilità bene visto che credo che
ted più di ogni altro incontro si era si
basi sulla verità come prima verità vi
dico subito che io
non vivo in centro
io non sono il vino suns e via metri
dall'altro abbiamo sempre detto che
quando si cammina si lasciano tre
impronte persona mestiere personaggio
cosa non deve non è che faccia da attore
ma vale anche per voi persona competenze
e ruolo tolti i parenti amici io credo
che la maggior parte degli altri ci
considerano ci percepiscono per del
terzo impronta per il luogo ed è per
questo che il nostro lavoro e li fa
fluire e diventare autentici quando il
ruolo personaggio che sostenuto dalle
competenze
corrisponde poi e fa affluire la quota
della persona quindi essere in modo che
nel personaggio ed è questo che fa la
differenza fa per noi i tori bomb per
tutti e quatto quanta parte di te e del
tuo ruolo perché noi non siamo quello
che facciamo come lo facciamo e come
faccio io organico anche perché questo
faccio come certo fare il bravo nei
peggiori locali della città nelle
periferie dove fare uno spettacolo non è
resi dire un testo un talento ma erano
più un confronto costante di casi umani
dove da una parte c'era una persona
pensante che pensava che il suo pensiero
forse un inevitabile e supremo e
dall'altra tu su pato che cerca di
raccontare il tuo mondo in questi luoghi
vari
moltissimo l'utilizzo del motto della
dinastia han colpirne uno per educarne
cento ed è vero ragione anzi l'abilità e
proprio luce la colpa a colpirlo in in
anticipo ma ciò che vale nei locali nei
off forse oggi neanche più nei locali
nostra sicuramente non vale
quell'atteggiamento
sconsigliato con l'atteggiamento né
quando usi la pubblicità per creare una
relazione è potuto narrazione
professionale ricordo che ero a bologna
fine
tratte dove lavorava per uno dei network
più importanti italiani e radiofonici in
uno degli eventi più importanti della
automotive terremoto c'è un evento nel
pieno della mia soddisfazione gorica
centinaia di persone che ridevano 1 di
fronte a me proprio di fronte meno video
e quindi la mia cucina interino di gela
ma perché quel nessuna non è stata
coinvolta dato talento e quindi i
cominciai a pensare così quasi fatto
direttamente glielo chiedo che sono
sceso dal palco ma dal bacoli che se
voleva studio perché lei non ride più è
morto il gatto cosa che faceva ridere le
altre persone non vale nulla di che
provi sheen poco dopo tra gli applausi
del pubblico
e quando arriva in quinta invece il mio
direttore marketing e mi sollevò
pesantemente e vincendo la forza di
gravità mi chiese sai chi era quello lì
che non rideva
quello che le moto il gatto si quello
era il ceo dell'azienda per cui stava
lavorando ora li apro puntato due
possibilità da una parte dovevo alzare
la mia barriera eroica e dire io sono
artista per cui viene così iniziano le
prove altro dall'altra invece la
possibilità di prendere questa
esperienza farne lezione e incominciare
a capire a cercare approfondire una
comicità inclusiva
perché anche un simbolo valore
universale credo che sul nome citando
riflettuto scritto parlato
garantiti dalle stoffa né di randello
freud persona di essere qua e parlarne
io
ma diciamo che la sintesi che posso fare
evasa sono quattro elementi la comicità
esistesse ci sono quattro elementi
una funzione che è una astrazione di
sensibilità e 4 la curiosità è un azione
collettiva la capacità di imporre di
mettere in connessione informazioni in
modo completamente diverso il modo
paradossale è sorprendente i tre punti
invece
precedenti come la community la vittima
e l'astrazione sensibilità sono il mio
focus di oggi come trasformare una
community in un gruppo sociale come
bloccare una vittima destro complice e
come portare un'astrazione di
sensibilità e consapevolezza la
community che cos'è la risata non è mai
solitaria la risata è un'esperienza
collettiva anche quando vivi con te
stesso non vi dicono sterili con
l'intero universo di nonno diceva rieti
che il ciel l'aiuta in parte
assolutamente vero ma soprattutto la
community un gruppo di persone che sono
insieme a cercando regole scritte non
scritte ad esempio di come essere dentro
un forno a community considera la casa
si raccontava quello che era successo in
classe che era la cosa più paradossale e
assurda che aveva fatto ridere per gli
ultimi 25 minuti alla guida ora tornati
al canto lo raccontava i tuoi noi non
cambiamo un'espressione se non alla fine
quando dirige uno scusa ma in matematica
cos'è il preso perché essenzialmente non
è che mi facevano ridere quello che era
accaduto non mi faceva ridere la
community non erano per meglio dire in
dono nella community la più di un valore
anche sociale nel senso quando ride un
gruppo non ride solo perché condivide la
struttura della battuta marine
soprattutto perché condivide il testo è
sotto destro la vittima è il nocciolo
della questione
chi è cos'è la vita di politica
incongruenza l'errore ed il l'oggetto
dell'azione comica il comico invece
utilizza il terzo punto un'astrazione di
sensibilità ovvero se partecipi
emotivamente non c'è risata immaginate
di camminare per strada è trovare un
imprevisto da bill banchina vado e se
neanche regalato abbiamo e no se mi
fosse capitato perché rende conto che
una volta
rialzati tutti quelli che grati e non i
vostri amici perché è in quel momento
che sono accorti che tu stai bene non si
sono più preoccupati emotivamente qui
già solo considerato il fatto che il
play preso ma cosa fa decisamente rivela
sentite male come si può sviluppare una
relazione con la vittima basata
sull'insensibilità dicevo che o due
gradini e insensibilità che mi permette
di ridere con la vittima o ridere della
vittima in modo anche molto semplice ma
non a sort si classifico di percorso di
sensibilità diciamo che si parte dalla
sense of humour cogliere l'incongruenza
certa velocità poi si prendo distacco
dalla vittima incomincio a forma di
cinismo in quanto cinesi po di giornali
più condiviso neanche della comunità in
parte della community che diventa
sarcasmo fino se vuoi apatia a quel
punto lì non te ne frega di ditte degli
altri quindi la tua azione economica in
molto incisiva e molto offensiva nei
confronti della vittima la cosa migliore
è utilizzare la capacità nella relazione
è che la vittima sia il primo stare bene
ecco perché esistono due tipi di
pubblicità a vendere della vittima
tutti gli altri di ridere ma la vittima
difficilmente lo farà si chiude e spesso
e volentieri linguaggio non verbale con
un'unica molto di più di quello verbale
quindi è facile che le persone intorno
alla vittima hanno percepiscono il suo
risate mentre ridere con la vittima che
era l'obiettivo non è più far ridere gli
altri ma fa ridere la vittima cioè
riportata dallo stato di disagio in uno
stato di confort per mettere lui in modo
consapevole
consapevole di comunicare il suo stato e
permetterà reati e di stare nuovamente a
proprio agio tra l'altro il pubblico che
vive con ridere ti si chiude dopo perché
ha paura di essere la prossima vittima
il pubblico coinvolto come leader e con
è frutto si rilasserà un meglio e più
pronto ad essere il duo complice la
state più interessante per ridere con e
che proprio l'azione che permette la
trasformazione da vittima o complice
attorno al 2010 sono i primi anni di
accenderla nel 2000 era uno spettacolo
in zona periferica di milano teatro
della cooperativa teatro di quartieri lo
riporta alla cultura nei quartieri anche
più difficili e dopo un successo nella
stagione ci chiamavano per sostituire
un'altra compagnia cosa che io pensai e
di non riportare lo spettacolo che va
che l'ha portato ma di portare un nuovo
progetto che tra l'altro era a specchio
sullo spettacolo cioè di portare tutte
le parti che avevano tagliato
molto più dirette molto più irriverenti
e quindi visto luce vano chiamato loro
mi sembrava opportuno se ne sta di fatto
che la coincidenza cosmica fa sì che a
differenza del primo aspettato la cava
portato un sacco di centemero polini di
comunicazione se non sto qui entra nel
dettaglio
prima inserire in scena il responsabile
de atocha raggiunge in camerino e ci
dice c'è poca gente a sera e non si
proviene da nato a san vito a te a fare
spettacolo il 30 durante la sola non è
un problema di locale di sarkozy lovino
sono in sei si dove vige una legge non
scritta che si va in scena se c'è una
persona in più del numero degli attori
dona ventura che non è più il 3 era già
c'era già il doppio delle persone e poi
di sia a mio socio non pensiamo alle sei
persone pensiamo ai migliaia di cellule
che ci stanno aspettando e quindi tutto
sommato era con un confronto una nutrita
platea sta di fatto che quando si arriva
sul palco non era soltanto sei persone
erano due realtà completamente diversa
una famiglia composta da papà ma una
figlia e figlio e dall'altra parte due
studenti universitari probabilmente
fuori corso quindi in quel momento avevo
assolutamente l'urgenza di cambiare il
mio linguaggio se non avrei perso la mia
community e soprattutto avrei messo il
disagio quella famiglia e la vittima in
quel caso sarebbe stato due le vite la
bava in a ma sicuramente e quindi decisi
se non lo so ce n'è un istante di
portare il loose del testo in che i due
ragazzini di 7 10 anni potevano
permettersi tra l'altro fu un'esperienza
straordinaria il testo così una dignità
impressionante molto di più di quello
che non so
perché non ero caduto nella banalità sta
di fatto che anche di foehn successo
quest'anno sono passati quindici di
quasi 11 anni durante un conto di chi è
contro le scuole per apportare al top
che ci succede agli artisti una ragazza
sola mano e chiese capacità di
intervenire loro domanda e mi disse io
le devo molto perché faccio teatro
grazie a non solo spettacolo il rose
bowl è mai spettacolo fuori dal fatto
che cosa così utile e ora con la mia
famiglia circa una decina di anni fa in
un piccolo teatro di periferia e lenny
fece ridere moltissimo questo fondi
meeting più belli della mia carriera
milano la mia città ha nel dna la utero
nia all'inclusione lo dico perché un
altro grande meno estrema sono danze
quando ha scritto il mio quella mattina
conclude proprio dicendo venite su senza
paura mi allungheremo la mano perché
questa è la città gialle dito del 1000
dirigerlo chi viene a milano e in cambio
di lavoro avrebbe avuto la libertà e
possiedono st libertà dovesse dipendere
dall utilizzo della comicità
ricordate che non potete oggi puoi dire
alla fine è solo una battuta le gravità
perché l'eroe detto non è una battuta è
una stazione di sensibilità quindi da
ogni dipenderà da voi cosa farli nella
vostra ironia io vi voglio nascere con
queste due immagini della mia vita
sospesa una parte della fiera a bologna
dove con iride reti
io l'ho sospeso grazie al mio direttore
marketing dall'altra la mia vita sospesa
dalla gratitudine perché ha usato
nella vostra vita
la scelta tra the fall a voi grazie a
una cosa deve al mio personaggio
spiega milano una ladrona già una
preghiera laica tavoletta più importante
non ha neanche bitcoin e intendo quindi
grazie del tempo che avete dedicato a
questa follia di vita di un gol